a lot of hot mics this week at the NATO
summit in the UK and now Donald Trump
has been caught on one so I told you
that Donald Trump after finding out that
other world leaders were laughing about
him he is a literal laughingstock among
world leaders he threw a tantrum he left
the NATO summit early but he also
insulted Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau after that happened
Trump was caught on a recording
congratulating himself about the funny
zinger of an insult against Trudeau
calling him two-faced so let's go
through it piece by piece first here is
Donald Trump calling Justin Trudeau
two-faced you be the judge about how
much of a biting zinger criticism this
was well he's too fast I find him to be
a very nice guy but you know the truth
is that I told him out of the fact that
he's not paying 2% okay and then Trump
later really apparently thinking that
that was a great insult caught on a hot
mic saying wasn't that so funny when I
called Justin Trudeau two-faced
it was funny when I said two guys crash
it oh yeah it was super funny when you
said he was two-faced right who who else
heard it because that was really funny
guys did you hear me this is
cringe-worthy this this is like the kid
in school who one time said something
that was like a 2 out of 10 on the
humour scale and then for weeks at every
opportunity brings it up remember that
time when I said that one thing oh yeah
but we're talking about something else
oh yeah no but it reminded me of that
time where I said that really funny
thing don't don't you guys remember how
funny that was that it that's what this
reminded me of this is such an insecure
person at heart he's giving a
blow-by-blow of
just a lame comeback to remind people of
how he really got the last word and came
out on top before he fled back to his
airplane and flew back to the United
States what's super clear from this is
that Donald Trump is really embarrassed
as he should be now I know a lot of
people say David he's not embarrassed
he's he's unable to feel shame he always
thinks he acted correctly I think that
it's a combination I think it's a
combination of his delusions of grandeur
but he is embarrassed to some degree it
might be perceived as anger he may even
see it as anger but at this point it's
clear that deep down somewhere in there
there is embarrassment there and this is
all he can do to fight back and in some
sense it's sad in another sense it is
hilarious to watch it from the sidelines
but the big picture that I want to
mention is that this is so emblematic of
the problems in the world right now
world leaders are caught expressing
concern about Donald Trump's bizarre
behavior in other words world leaders
when they think people aren't listening
or when they don't think they're being
recorded they're talking about how odd
and disturbing Donald Trump's behavior
is Trump gets hot put caught on a hot
mic and he's just praising himself for a
quite frankly not very funny insult that
he told and reminding people around him
how funny it was this is a microcosm of
everything that is taking place right
now and it can't end soon enough the
David Pakman show is possible thanks to
sponsors like VIN Charo watches giving
everyone in our audience 15% off your
entire order when you
to david pakman.com slash watch I just
got a couple of new watches from these
guys and I love them I got the Kairos
limited release gold reserve set which
is very cool I love the white face the
simple band and everything about it it's
a perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether
in silver and white and what I love
about this one
number one the Roman numeral at the top
of the face the white face is great this
is a chronograph model and I love the
blue leather band it's just a really
nice looking watch everybody who sees me
wear this one always asks about it what
I like about Vince arrow as a watch
brand is you're getting quality and
you're getting a watch where it's clear
as soon as you open the box that a lot
of care and artisanship went into the
design and the way that the watch is put
together I'm not interested in paying
thousands of dollars for a watch when I
can get one that's reasonably priced and
looks just as nice and has terrific
build quality and that's exactly what
Vince arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link